lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
conectar todavía más el teorema del
binomio con el triángulo de pascal y con
la combinatoria aunque entonces tenemos
aquí x más elevado a la tercera potencia
y estamos viendo esto nada más como un
ejemplo para que sea más fácil
entenderlo pero bueno el chiste es que
esto es igual a x + d por otra vez x +
por otra vez x + y para no estarnos
confundiendo con a cuál x me refiero o
aquello me refiero a este paréntesis le
vamos a llamar el paréntesis 1 a este
paréntesis le vamos a llamar el
paréntesis 2 ya este el 3 entonces a la
hora de ver el desarrollo de este
binomio al cubo pues tenemos por aquí un
término x porque al cuadrado pero pues
al coeficiente de este x por ya al
cuadrado tiene que ver con de cuántas
formas de estos tres paréntesis puede
escoger dos de esos paréntesis para que
me den una
y cuadrada y que el otro paréntesis me
dé esta x de ahí es de donde viene este
coeficiente que son las combinaciones de
tres en dos porque tenemos tres
paréntesis y de esos tres paréntesis
queremos escoger dos porque ya la
estamos elevando al cuadrado entonces de
dos de estos paréntesis tenemos que
sacarla y en lugar de la equis porque
hay entonces este coeficiente tiene que
ser cuántas formas hay de escoger dos
elementos de un conjunto de tres
elementos y eso es justo lo que este
símbolo de las combinaciones de tres en
dos representa entonces pues vámonos al
triángulo de pascal para ver qué es más
o menos la misma idea aunque vamos a
tomar el mismo término x porque al
cuadrado x porque al cuadrado y bueno a
mí con el triángulo de pascal lo que me
gusta es pensar que esto es simplemente
un mapa y que cada una de estas cosas es
un nodo del mapa y que estas líneas
indican que d
expresión si puedo llegar a esta
expresión y bueno para llegar de esta
expresión de este nuevo a este nodo lo
único que tengo que hacer es multiplicar
por una y de hecho por eso lo colorea de
azul y de este nodo también podemos
llegar a esta expresión y lo único que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar por una
equis y por eso lo colorea de rosa
entonces en el nivel anterior hay
exactamente dos nodos que pueden llegar
a este nuevo que nos interesa sin
embargo la cantidad de formas de llegar
a este nodo son dos y la cantidad de
formas de llegar a este nodo es une
entonces todas las formas que hay de
llegar a este novo pues tiene que ser la
suma de dos más uno o sea que hay tres
formas de llegar a este nuevo y bueno
ahora vamos a conectar este triángulo de
pascal con todo lo que estábamos
haciendo por acá
ok cada que tenemos un nudo y bajamos de
nivel tenemos que escoger cuál de los
dos caminos tomamos la
y yo lo veo es que cuando estamos en un
nodo y escogemos alguno de los dos
caminos ya sea el rosa o el azul pues
estamos escogiendo multiplicar por una
equis o multiplicar por una y y eso lo
podemos ver en estos paréntesis como que
ya llevamos cierto camino recorrido o
sea que ya escogimos o está x o está ahí
o este x o está ahí y entonces estamos
en este punto y ahora estamos escogiendo
si nos vamos por el camino rosa es [ __ ]
multiplicar por esta x o si nos vamos
por el camino azul es [ __ ] multiplicar
por ésta y ok entonces saber aquí
teníamos los paréntesis numerados así es
que vamos a enumerar estos paréntesis
también este paréntesis es este
paréntesis que es el paréntesis 1 este
es el paréntesis 2 y el paréntesis 3 en
este término estamos diciendo que hay
tres formas de llegar a x porque
cuadrada entonces pues vamos a ver
cuáles son esos tres caminos podemos
empezar por escoger una x
y después escoger una y otra y ese es un
camino y es equivalente a escoger del
primer paréntesis está x lo cual es
escoger este camino y en el segundo
paréntesis pues escogimos una porque
tomamos el camino azul entonces
escogimos esta lleve este paréntesis y
después volvimos a escoger una y ok y si
te fijas para llegar de aquí acá lo que
tenemos que hacer es escoger una vez el
camino hacia la izquierda y dos veces el
camino hacia la derecha
ok porque necesitamos nada más una equis
que la obtenemos con un camino hacia la
izquierda y necesitamos dos ges que son
los caminos hacia la derecha los caminos
azules entonces otra vez estamos en el
mismo problema de antes ok vamos a
escoger uno de los dos caminos que es
multiplicar por equis o multiplicar por
ye y tenemos que hacer eso
a ver vamos a ver cuál es otro camino
que podemos hacer podemos tomar primero
a la derecha multiplicando por y luego
multiplicar por equis a la izquierda y
volver a multiplicar porque a la derecha
y eso es como escoger del primer
paréntesis una y del segundo paréntesis
una equis y del tercer paréntesis otra
vez una y y nada más nos queda una
última forma de llegar a este término
que es primero multiplicar por una y a
la derecha luego volver a multiplicar
por una llega a la derecha y finalmente
multiplicar por una equis hacia la
izquierda y esto es equivalente a del
primer paréntesis escoger la y del
segundo paréntesis es [ __ ] otra vez la
ye y del tercer paréntesis es [ __ ] la
equis entonces viendo las matemáticas
básicas que hay de fondo estos dos
problemas son exactamente la misma cosa
de un conjunto de tres elementos escoger
dos y esas son las combinaciones de tres
en dos o key de tres pasos hacia abajo
que tenemos que dar los tres pasos dos
de ellos tienen que ser hacia la derecha
y uno tiene que ser hacia la izquierda
la cantidad de formas de hacer eso la
denotamos por las combinaciones de tres
en dos que es también igual a la
cantidad de formas que hay de escoger
dos paréntesis para que esos paréntesis
nos den una y cuando tenemos tres
paréntesis de los cuales tenemos que
escoger si multiplicamos x oye